what does it actually mean visually what
does it mean it's not that hard to
illustrate think about it with me
let's let's do the same function okay
because e to the x is nice
because when you integrate it doesn't go
anywhere okay so
if i think about what e dx looks like
from naught to a
okay there's the area i'm after
okay what is this saying what are you
saying i suppose this is this is what
makes it excessive
two rather than extension one
understanding how
e to the x is different to e to the
a minus x that transformation that's
something that you guys special in
isn't it there are two changes what are
they
number one there's a horizontal flip
because of the negative what's the other
change
there's a shift okay so let's do them
one at a time
if i've got my graph here i'll do it in
another color uh which should we do
first be careful
should i should i flip or should i shift
first flip first okay so therefore
i'm getting something like that okay
that's been flipped
now the a what does that do which way am
i going left or right
right left right
you kind of have a bit of an advantage
because you know what you should get
right you know you ought to get that
area
from not to a so that's why you can know
it's this way okay
so this is actually what you're going to
expect my curvature is a bit off
so here you go i'll do it a bit better
like this
that's e to the a minus x okay so you
can see
what compares you've got the same area
don't you from naught
to a right it's always useful to see
that because
really you'll be using these results
like sometimes you just get asked to
prove it but other times you'll be asked
to
use it they'll just give you some weird
area you'll be like how do i integrate
that
how do i actually evaluate and the
answer is you use one of these kinds of
identities
right last thing before i leave up it
this one's really
important because it's where you get our
results for
um odd and even functions odd and even
functions right so for instance
let's call odd sorry let's call f odd
okay
so that would mean the f of negative x
is equal to
negative f of x that's that's what an
odd function is okay so
how would that play out here what would
happen
well you're going to get in here right
um sorry start again you're going to
have
the integral on these boundaries
right and then you say from naught to a
but as you're writing you're like wait
wait a second that f minus x i don't
need to write that i can write that in
terms of the original function
so what you get in here cancels out
right so you get your integral of zero
right which is what you expect
because you know it's a symmetrical
thing and that's what
functions look like okay you can do
exactly the same thing for an even
function
which has this result right so when you
go from here to here
and you use this result here you can say
that's f
as well which is
why you put your two out the front right
so you guys it's fine to say
by symmetry because odd and even
functions are about symmetry
um but you know mathematicians are
satisfied with just saying because it
looks like it right
they want this kind of thing so this is
the actual proof
the results you've been using for quite
some time now with simple questions
okay